[Music]
it is the car industry's big summer day
out at a test track near Bedford big
engines petrol hybrids electric most of
these there were imports but they still
rely on British parts flying across the
channel but now because of brexit
European governments are telling their
businesses to avoid UK parts the
official Dutch government advice seen by
Sky News warns businesses trade with the
United Kingdom will become more
difficult to have to brexit this may
affect your company but also your
suppliers or customers consider looking
for alternatives within the EU when the
product or service is essential for your
own business operations and after brexit
the United Kingdom is no longer part of
the EU so parts from the United Kingdom
no longer count towards this minimum
production in the EU
keep in mind any consequences concerning
the reduction of orders this is all
about the parts that make up cars and
planes
it's about rules of origin vital for
cross-border manufacturing in order to
qualify as an EU export 55% of the total
value needs to come from the EU what the
Dutch advise is that UK parts do not
count I think what the Dutch government
are saying to their businesses makes
perfect sense from a trade point of view
there is a risk that they don't know
what will happen with the UK and EU
relationship in March 2019 be ready and
that may involve sourcing your parts for
your finished products from inside the
EU rather than a country that's leaving
and it's not just the Dutch from here at
rotterdam port the european commission
itself has just put out a notice to EU
factories making a similar warning about
UK parts but the rules of origin issue
is a two-way problem for post brexit
britain about what will and will not
qualify as a UK export under the
much-heralded post breaks its free trade
deals promised by this government rules
of origin are these small print of free
trade deals with big implications that
kick in if we're no longer part of a
customs union with the EU
for example for cars being exported from
Tilbury Docks the government has
previously argued that we are very close
to meeting the sorts of thresholds that
will enable a British car to be a
British car under a free trade deal but
Sky News understands that the industry
has told number ten directly that we are
in fact miles off car industry Chief
Mike halls confirmed that to Sky News
the actual figure is more like twenty
five percent if the target is fifty five
sixty five percent it shows the
difference in the distance we would have
to go the government has been going
around thinking it's more like forty
four forty five percent now the UK
automotive industry on average by is
about forty four percent of its products
from a UK supplier but that's not what
rules of origin is you have to look at
something called originating content
what proportion of the content actually
comes from the UK in our instance that
is more like twenty to twenty five
so as far as cars go on average they
won't even qualify for the free trade
deals with the government is anxious to
sign by leaving the customs union Sky
News put this to the trade secretary
could it possibly be that cars made in
the UK might not qualify for some of the
free trade deals you hope to be signing
well in any trade agreement rules of
origin as they're called is always an
important element and you can't prejudge
any one trade agreement but we would
want to ensure that anything that we
signed up to was able to maximize UK
sale of goods why would you sign up to
something that wasn't actually going to
give you a trading advantage but this
former trade department insider said
that warnings were made to the very top
of government we knew there would be a
stick learning curve for ministers the
Prime Minister in issues of trade I
think I've been more surprised by the
lack of engagement with business that
meant that these messages didn't come
through clearly and quickly enough
essentially they wanted from business
really to just talk about the
opportunities they didn't want to hear
about the possible threats that would
come with with brexit they didn't want
to hear about the whole picture today
you're talking about Downing Street my
number 10 you took my the Prime Minister
thinks oh yes
all this comes that's an already
delicate time in the car industry
privately aghast at the chances of
attracting big battery factories in the
UK that need to be able to be used by
Continental manufacturers of new cars
the industry the government's want the
car industry to go fully
tens
billions of pounds of investments
investments that may be lacking because
of brigade's uncertainty and the
government at the very top seems to
barely understand so right now these
rules of origin mean that Europeans can
shun UK parts and for now British cars
won't even qualify as British for free
trade deals just like a car brexit is
all in the detail Faisal Islam Sky News